>> Gayle Osterberg:
Good morning.
Good morning, everyone.
How are you all today?
Great. My name is
Gayle Osterberg.
I'm the director
of communications
for the Library of Congress.
We work really hard for months
to put this program together
for you and so it's really
exciting when you come
into an auditorium and see
people who are here and excited
to hear from our authors
and spend a great day
with maybe finding some new
authors, some new books,
and celebrating reading.
So thank you all so
much for being here.
I want to also take a minute
to say a big thank you
to our festival sponsors.
This event not only
would not be free,
but it just wouldn't happen
at all without the generosity
of many sponsors:
David Rubenstein,
"The Washington Post,"
the Institute for Museum
and Library Services as well
as Wells Fargo and many others.
Many of our sponsors
are exhibiting
down on the Expo floor.
So if you have a minute
today, please go down there
and say thank you for
their support of reading
and of this great event.
I would also invite you to
consider donating yourself.
It's very easy, loc.gov/donate.
No contribution is too small
and it will help ensure
that this event can
continue in the future.
One of the sponsors downstairs
is PBS and I would also
like to make you aware of a new
series that they will be rolling
out this fall called
The Great American Read.
They did a wonderful
launch episode
with host Meredith
Vieira earlier this year.
They surveyed readers like
yourselves across the country
and came up with a list of
America's 100 favorite novels
and are encouraging you to read
those throughout the summer
and to vote for your favorites.
And then this fall, there will
be a great series highlighting
some of the different books
on the list and counting
down the favorite novels
that folks have voted
on throughout the summer.
So I encourage you to take part
in that wonderful activity.
Now our next author, I'm
always so interested to hear
about the backgrounds
of some of the folks
that are writers today.
They're all extraordinary
authors
but also just really
extraordinary
and interesting people.
And our next author is an
investigative reporter whose
work has resulted in new
laws, criminal convictions,
and millions in restitution
for victims and consumers.
Her journalism has been
awarded more than 30 Emmys
and 14 Edward R. Murrow Awards
and that's before we
even get her books.
Her two series, the
Charlotte McNally series
and the Jane Ryland and
Jake Brogan thrillers are
national bestsellers.
She is the winner
of five Agathas
and the Mary Higgins
Clark award.
Her brand-new book, which
she is launching here
at the National Book Festival
from Forge Books is
called "Trust Me."
Has anyone had a
chance to read it yet?
Trust me when I tell you
that this book is a mind
twist of the first order.
I could not put it down.
Another best-selling
author described it as grief
and deception are at the helm
of Ryan's latest thriller
in which a crime writer
and an accused criminal's
lives collide, as they come
to discover that no one can
be trusted, not even oneself.
It is a book about the truth,
which to quote one
passage takes three forms:
what we think it is, how
someone presents it to us,
and what it really is.
I can't wait to hear her
talk about this book.
Please welcome for her National
Book Festival debut appearance,
Hank Phillippi Ryan.
[ Applause ]
>> Hank Phillippi
Ryan: Good morning.
Thank you so much
for coming here.
This is absolutely great.
I love coming to Washington, DC.
I lived here in the 70s
working on Capitol Hill
for the Senate Judiciary
Committee, Subcommittee
and for "Rolling
Stone Magazine."
So I always seem to come here
at interesting times, right.
I've been a television reporter
for 43 years, the first year
in Indianapolis and then
for a while in Atlanta
and for the past 33 years, I
can't believe it, in Boston.
I've wired myself
with hidden cameras.
I've confronted corrupt
politicians.
I've gone undercover
and in disguise
but I didn't always
plan to be a reporter.
I grew up in really
rural Indiana,
so rural that you couldn't see
another house from our house.
I used to ride my pony to
the library to get books
and I would fill up the
saddlebags with books
and then read up in the hayloft
of the barn behind our house
and that's where I fell
in love with mystery.
I read Nancy Drew.
You read Nancy Drew, right?
"The Clue in the Old Clock"
and "The Clue in the Diary,"
which I thought was clue in the
"dairy" for most of the book
and I kept thinking, you
know, shouldn't there be cows.
I don't know.
It was fine.
And then my parents lost me
for about a month when I was
up in the hayloft reading every
single Sherlock Holmes short
story and novella and
then I went on to, yeah,
and then I went on to
the golden-age mysteries,
Ngaio Marsh and Josephine
Tey and Dorothy Sayers, and,
of course, Agatha Christie.
That's when I really fell
in love with the mystery,
with the architecture
of that kind of a novel
where a smart author
could lure you in
and keep you turning the
pages and then in the end,
surprise you and have you
say, oh, I should've seen
that coming, but the author
was smarter than I am.
So I always wanted to be a
mystery author or a detective.
And as an investigative reporter
and a crime fiction author,
I guess I am a little
bit of each.
My life did not go the
way it was planned.
I was in college.
I was a Shakespeare major,
much to my parents chagrin.
My mom is like, oh, honey, you
know, you are never to be able
to get a job, you know
you're unemployable.
And then after college
I went to work
in several political
campaigns back home in Indiana.
Sadly, not one candidate I
ever worked for actually won.
So this is one of those moments
when the universe is sort
of telling you "find
another career."
So I decided that my new
career would be in journalism.
So I went to the biggest
radio station in Indianapolis
and I went to the news director
and I said I'm here to apply
for the job as a reporter.
And he proceeded to ask me all
about my experience in radio
and television and
journalism, which was zero,
at which point he said,
I'm so sorry, you know,
you seem like a perfectly
fine young woman,
but I just can't hire you.
You have absolutely no
experience whatsoever.
He said but look, can you
just give me one good reason,
this was 1970, I
should remind you,
he said can you give me one good
reason why I should hire you.
And I said, well, yeah,
you know, I can actually.
I said your license is up for
renewal at the FCC right now
and you don't have
any women working here
and then I just smiled.
And the next day I had my first
job in broadcasting [applause].
I know. When you're 20,
when you're 20, you know,
you're much more brave than
you are when you realize
that people are going
to tell you no.
But I started writing fiction --
I've been a television
reporter ever since.
I started writing fiction
about ten years ago
when I just had a good idea.
You know that feeling
when you have a good idea
and you get goose bumps
and you think, wow,
this is going to work.
And I went home and I said
to my husband, sweetheart ,
I'm going to write the novel
I've always wanted to write.
I have a good idea
for a mystery.
And Jonathan says, great.
Do you know how,
honey, to write a novel?
And I'm like how hard can it be?
You know, I've read
a million of these.
So I soon realized, of
course, how hard it could be.
I'm thrilled to be here
with my tenth novel,
my first standalone, a
psychological standalone,
which came out really
two days ago.
So I'm so excited to
share that with you.
You know about elevator
pitches, right?
You know what that is.
They tell you that if you
find yourself in an elevator
with Steven Spielberg and he
pushes 25 and you have 25 floors
with him and he says,
what's your book about that
that you better be
able to tell him.
So if I were in an
elevator with you,
that'd be weird because
it's big.
If I were in an elevator with
you, I would tell you that
"Trust Me" is one
obsessed journalist --
One buzz saw, can you
hear that next door?
That "Trust Me" is one obsessed
journalist, one troubled mom,
and they face off in a
high-stakes cat-and-mouse game
to prove their truth about a
gruesome and terrible murder.
The question is which one is the
cat and which one is the mouse
and I dare you to find the liar.
Let me show you a
cool thing about that.
In looking for the liar, I mean
I love the cover of "Trust Me."
It's beautiful, right?
But if you look at it this
way, see what it says?
Can you see that it says "liar?"
Is that so great?
Right? Isn't that cool.
Somebody's really smart.
Yeah, it's very cool.
So let me tell you a little bit
about where "Trust
Me" came from.
First, let me tell you
that my husband Jonathan
and I don't celebrate the
anniversary of the day we met.
We celebrate the anniversary
of the day before we met
and we call that
"you never know day,"
because you never know
what wonderful thing is
around the next corner.
Isn't that kind of true?
You know, on the days that
you're disappointed or unhappy
and you think, oh my
goodness, I'm doomed
and nothing good is ever
going to happen to me again.
How often does it happen
that something wonderful
happens right after that
out of the adversity of that?
And that is precisely
how "Trust Me," was born,
another "you never know day."
Remember the Casey
Anthony trial?
You do, right?
You remember that the
notorious Florida party girl mom
who was accused of the
murder of her young daughter,
of hiding the body and then
lying about it for a month.
Well, here's an inside scoop.
I was hired back then by a
big fancy publishing company
to write the narrative
nonfiction
of the Casey Anthony trial.
It was going to be
a big bestseller,
if all went as planned.
And you know how
often that happens.
So I had to have the
book done on the day
that Casey Anthony was sentenced
to life in prison because,
of course, that was exactly
what was going to happen.
And my deadline was fierce
because I only had started
writing as the trial began.
So I worked like a crazy person.
I had three computers
going at the same time:
one for watching the trial, one
for researching the background
and history and family
story of Casey Anthony
and the Anthony family,
and one for writing.
One for viewing, one
for researching,
and one for writing.
I worked all the time.
I worked a million hours a day.
It had to be fascinating
and brilliant and insightful
and thoughtful and it
had to be done on time.
There was no question
about that.
Now here's a confession
as I wrote.
Here's a confession.
As I wrote, I was thinking
this is really good.
That was doomed.
I loved writing it.
It was so enthralling.
I got to tell a true story
like I do in my TV stories
but because I had more
time and space in the book,
it could be bigger
and deeper and richer,
still with every fact correct
but with every suspenseful
turning point.
But in this book, unlike
television, I also got to talk
about how people were thinking
and what they were planning
and what their motivations were.
So it was perfect.
I got to use my TV skills to
take a lot of complicated stuff
and make it fascinating and
interesting and compelling
and my fiction writing skills
to make a page-turner of a story
with a big crime
with stranger-than-fiction
characters and endless suspense.
In fact, just to reveal a little
bit more ridiculously personal
stuff, I thought I
had found my calling.
You know how it feels when
you're really into something?
I will confess to you that
I thought this is going
to be the next "In Cold Blood."
This is what I'm going to do.
I'm going write narrative
nonfiction.
I rock this.
And here, here's even
another admission.
I wrote the outline
-- I wrote outline
for the verdict scene before
the verdict even happened.
I was that confident
about what was going
to happen in the trial.
I thought that's going to be so
easy because she is so guilty.
Well, you know what
happened next, right?
She was acquitted.
And boom, my book was killed.
Publisher called and said, thank
you so much but no thank you.
We don't need that now.
Thanks for all your
hard work and goodbye.
Can you believe that?
Now as the wife of a criminal
defense attorney, I had to say,
good, you know, the
system worked again.
That's what's supposed
to happen.
But as the rest of me, that
profoundly affected me.
That experience profoundly
changed me and here's why.
I realized a couple of things.
One, I realized that that jury
had somehow taken a story I
thought I knew and come up
with the exact opposite opinion
of what had actually happened.
How could that be that two
sets of facts could be thought
of in exactly opposite ways.
How could my way
have been so wrong?
And then and also as affecting,
I realized that I had been
writing this true crime book
from the perspective
that she was guilty.
And I really hadn't
thought about it that way.
I believed she was, so
what I was writing was true
because it was true for me.
Now that was actually kind of
upsetting because, of course,
I thought I was writing it
from a perfectly
objective point of view.
And then I thought --
And stay with me here
because this is the brain
of someone whose book
had just been killed.
I thought what if I was right?
What if I actually had written
the true story, but the jury,
based on the evidence that they
had, just disagreed with me.
Could there be two truths?
And then I realized there are
three sides to every story.
Yours, mine and the truth.
So the manuscript got
tossed and I chalked that up
to experience and
my life went on.
But then, part two happened.
My darling husband Jonathan
was the defense attorney
in a really notorious
murder case
in Boston, the Bella Bond case.
You may have heard of it.
It was called "the Baby
Doe trial" for a while
because they couldn't
identify the body
of the little girl
whose body was tossed
in Boston harbor
in a garbage bag.
The night before
closing arguments,
I listened to Jonathan,
my husband,
practice what he would say,
what he would tell the jury.
And as he told the story, I
nodded in total agreement.
His client, the child's mother's
boyfriend, had been accused
of the murder, but the facts
as Jonathan told them were
so compelling and so convincing
and so true, it was so clear
to me and it was so
evident as Jonathan talked
that his client was not guilty
at all, absolutely not guilty.
And I said to him, sweetheart,
this is a slam dunk acquittal.
And then I thought about the
prosecutor's wife, across town,
sitting at their kitchen
table and she was listening
to her prosecutor husband
give his closing arguments,
practice his closing arguments.
And, of course, in that closing
argument, he'd select the facts
that would create a
completely different story,
a story of guilt.
And did his wife, I wonder,
turn to him and say, oh,
sweetheart, slam
dunk conviction.
Did she do that?
And how can that be?
And it was so thought-provoking
to me the question of justice
and truth and how the same
set of facts can be used
in two different ways to come
up with two completely
different stories
about the same terrible crime.
And was either of them true?
Three sides to every story:
yours, mine and the truth.
So, here's how my writer
brain worked on that.
Could I, I wonder,
write a thriller
where two different people
tell polar opposite stories
with polar opposite explanations
about the exact same murder,
using exactly and only
the same facts but come
up with different truths?
That would be such fun, such
a great challenge to write.
Wouldn't it?
It would be so important,
too, I thought,
to reveal how our biases and
emotions color our truths.
There's what we're told is true.
There's what we believe is true.
And then there's the truth.
And I loved that idea so much.
So Rubik's cubing all those
all the stuff into my story,
here's how my writer
brain worked on that.
I have a young magazine
writer, Mercer Hennessey,
who lives in a suburb of
Boston called Lansdale,
which I made up.
She's left her burgeoning career
as a journalist to stay home
with her new young daughter
and her beloved husband.
She's decided to give up
her career for her family.
When there is a tragic accident
and this happens on page one,
her family is taken away.
She is so sad.
She is so bereaved.
She is so full of grief that she
cannot think of a reason to get
out of bed in the morning.
She even considers burning down
their house just to be done
with it all because
life has no meaning
and no reason anymore for her.
In fact, she starts her
day by writing numbers
in the condensation, the steam
condensation of the mirror
of the bathroom and
as the book open,
she writes for 442
in the mirror.
That's how many days it's been
since her family
was taken from her.
That's her ritual.
But then as the story opens,
more than a year later,
Mercer is offered the assignment
that might bring her back
into the real world, to
write a true crime narrative
of a riveting trial about
a gruesome terrible murder.
The defendant is a young woman
named Ashlyn Bryant and the book
that Mercer Hennessey writes
is her personal story as well
as the defendant's story and
that becomes the crucial cat
and mouse of this book.
Who's telling the truth
and what is the truth
and how do you write
a true crime novel?
How do you write a
true crime narrative
if you don't know the truth?
So Mercer decides to use
all of her reporter skills
to get the story that she wants.
And is that a good thing
because Mercer has some secrets
of her own?
I was really honored
to be featured
on Boston's NPR the other day.
And the person who interviewed
me on the radio asked me
to read a little bit of my
book and I never do that.
I have never done a seminar or
a session where I actually read
but the cool part was that she
picked the section she wanted me
to read, very tiny.
And I was so impressed with that
that I'm going to
do that now too.
First, here's the first page.
It's actually not
the first page.
It's actually pre-page one.
So you can sort of get a
sense of how the book feels.
This is the beginning
of "Trust Me."
"Using one forefinger, I write
on the bathroom mirror drawing
through the steamy
condensation left by the shower.
This morning's number is 442,
442 days since the car accident
that destroyed my family,
the crash that took
Dex and Sophie from me.
The numbers disintegrate
as I write them.
They melt into watery tears
and then they disappear.
I would give anything, anything,
I would do anything, longing,
unbitten hits me hard, unwanted
as I look at my reflection.
We make these offers every day,
filling in our own
personal blanks.
If you make this happen, we
promise, I'll give up drinking
or speeding, or whatever.
If you give me what I want,
I'll be a better daughter,
a more reliable husband,
a more devoted wife.
Make my wish come true
and I'll do anything.
We bargain, negotiate, make
deals with the universe.
Eventually, certainly,
inevitably we'll
get what we want.
And then the universe
laughs and we are left
to bargain with ourselves."
And as the story progresses,
Mercer is covering the trial
of Ashlyn Bryant and the jury
goes out and she's waiting
for the verdict and this is a
tiny bit of what happens to her
as she has finished her book
and is waiting for the verdict.
"Don't you people have a brain,"
I yell at the blank
court monitor screen?
Day five of deliberations
almost over.
No questions, no nothing, not
a peep for five full days.
I've sat at my desk writing
like crazy and fueled by coffee
and saltines and wine.
Going nuts.
What the hell is
that jury doing?
It means there's a holdout,
one local cable commentator
pontificated this morning.
You know nothing, I
answered the television.
There was no proven cause of
death, another suit agreed.
So the hell what?
I debated him too, jabbing
at him with a finger.
Dead is dead and
it was no accident.
That child was in a trash bag.
Moreover, I console myself
eating my salty cracker.
It's definitely possible that a
guilty verdict is in the making.
Jurors don't want to convict
someone, especially for a crime
that carries a life
sentence without appearing
to meticulously consider
all the evidence,
but the guilty verdict
could come any second.
Jurors took two days
to convict Jodi Arias
of killing an ex-boyfriend,
four days to convict
the Menendez brothers
of killing her parents, 11
days to convict Scott Peterson
of killing his wife Laci
and their unborn child.
On the other hand, that
idiot Florida jury only took
about two hours to
acquit Casey Anthony,
to acquit O.J. Simpson less
than four hours, four hours.
So a long deliberation has
to mean a guilty verdict.
I deeply relished that
Ashlyn must know that too."
So that's how -- That's
how the book feels.
And in writing this book,
let me just tell you,
I tried to find a cat and mouse
passage of the book to read
so you could see how Ashlyn
and Mercer deal with each other
but there was not one exchange
that does not give away
a clue in the book.
So you'll just have to read that
for yourself and have the fun
of making your own decisions
about who is telling the truth.
And you know, I followed my
own advice, my own realization
when I was writing this book.
I had no idea who was guilty.
I had no idea who was telling
the truth as I type chapter one.
It was all a surprise and
a pretty amazing one too.
You know, I don't use an outline
as I'm writing my novels.
I just start with this one
good idea, what is the essence
of truth and what about
a cat and mouse game
between a journalist
and a troubled mom.
And I type chapter one and I
just see what happens next.
So I don't know what happens
until I write the next line
and the next sentence
and the next paragraph
and the next scene.
And that's one of the
things that takes me
to the computer every
day is that I cannot wait
to see what happens next.
So when people say, wow,
the ending and trust me,
that really surprised me.
I'm like, yeah, wasn't
that a surprise?
You know, talk about
a surprise ending.
I surprised myself and I
surprise myself every day
and it's one of the things
that keeps me writing.
Let me ask you, let me ask you,
are any of you Game
of Thrones fans?
It doesn't -- Yes.
It doesn't matter if
you say yes or no.
But let me tell you this.
I met the author
George R. R. Martin
at the ThrillerFest Convention
a couple of weeks ago.
And after I got over my fan
girl terror, I went up to him
and I said, "I think
about you every day."
And he's like, "Really?
How come?"
And I mean, I could've
put a little more artfully
if I hadn't been so
nervous but okay.
So I said, here's why.
I said "because you
are so brave.
You'll do anything
in your novels.
You'll change everything.
You'll make the good guys
bad and the bad guys good
and you'll have terrible secrets
and you'll kill anyone,
you'll kill anyone!
You're not afraid to
take a risk," I told him,
and that's why when I'm
writing every day I say
to myself, what would George do.
Go for it and I'd go for it.
And he beamed at me and we got
a memorable picture together
and that's what "Trust Me."
is. "Trust Me" is big risk.
My other books are series.
So the reader knows no matter
what happens in those books
with Jane Ryland as
the main character,
the reader knows no matter
what happens in those books,
Jane Ryland is not going to
die, right, because she has
to come back for
books six and seven.
So the suspense in
the series comes
from the really interesting
and compelling story
that she is working
on and the murder case
that she has to solve.
But your fear is not
that she's going to die.
That's as a given.
But in a standalone like
"Trust Me," it's one and done.
It's not an exciting,
interesting moment
in somebody's life or career.
It is the biggest,
most compelling,
most tectonic plate shifting,
most life-changing thing
that has ever happened
or will ever happen
to the main characters,
it will ever happen.
It is one and done.
That's all and anything
could happen.
So in writing this
standalone, my first,
that was the revelation,
that anything could happen.
Every card could
be put on the table
and some shock the
heck out of me.
Anyone can be guilty.
Anyone could lie.
And anyone could die
because nobody has
to come back for book two.
Right? Booklist Starred Review
just called it a knockout,
first-rate psychological
suspense
and wonderful reviewer Lisa
Holstein [assumed spelling],
a fabulous librarian,
called it this, she says,
"It's this summer's "Gone
Girl," but I like it better."
So that's good.
I mean, that's good.
You know, I'm really
the poster child
for following your
dreams in midlife.
I didn't start writing
thrillers,
fiction until I was 55,
which was 13 years ago.
And I really at a time when
I had a wonderful career
as a television reporter, I'd
had some success and age 55.
Sometimes when people
say, well that's fine,
you've had a great life.
Sit back, rest on your
whatever laurels and just relax.
But that little girl
in the hayloft wanted
to write mysteries and I wanted
to do it and I wanted to feel
like that and I'm
really the living proof
that it's never too late
to follow your dreams
about what you want to do.
And if you take nothing from
this morning, except my book,
which is out now, if you take --
Okay, that was cheap, wasn't it?
But if you take nothing
from this morning,
I want you to understand
to think about what it is
that you'd like to do.
Did you want to write a novel
or write narrative nonfiction
or write a book of poetry or
put together that recipe book
that your family has been
clamoring for or teach someone
to read or do something
good or take a trip
or learn a new language or
explore your life, somehow?
I'm the prove that it's
never too late to do that.
Do you know the Stephen
Sondheim musical,
"Sunday in the Park
with George."
You know that.
It's a fabulous musical
about the French impressionist
pointillist painter
Georges Seurat.
And there's a scene in this --
There's a scene in this musical
where the Seurat character comes
out on the stage by himself
and he has a blank sketchpad.
And on the sketchpad,
he draws a hat.
And he looks at the sketchpad
and says, "Look, I made a hat
where there never was a hat."
And it's this realization
that he has created something
out of nothing and he
sings a song about it,
which I will not sing, a song
about creativity and a song
about imagination and
a song about how we
as human beings are the only
creatures who can do that.
We're the only ones who can
make something out of nothing
but our own imagination
and our own compulsion
and our own session
and our own creativity
and our own brainpower.
We can make art and music
and poetry and literature.
We're the only creatures
who can do that
and that's what I do
every day at my computer.
I'm making hats.
I'm making new hats.
I'm making new worlds that
only I can create that come
out of nothing but
my own imagination
and then you can meet
Mercer and Ashland,
characters who I have created
and who become real
because of that.
That is the astonishing
power of creativity.
And we embrace it.
It is my dream to live in this
world of books and learning
and writing and creativity.
When I finished "Trust Me," I
called my husband into the room
and I said, "Sweetheart,
watch this."
And I typed "the end" and
then I burst into tears.
I burst into tears because I
knew no matter what happened
after that, I had taken a risk.
I had written this book
that I wanted to write.
I had done something important.
I had done something big.
I had done something different.
And I had followed my dream.
But of course, I shouldn't have
burst into tears when I typed
"the end" because it
wasn't the end it all.
It was the beginning of this
wonderful new second half
of my life and career.
And I'm so pleased that
you came here today
to share that with me.
Thank you so much [applause].
Oh my goodness, thank you.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
I'm very honored to be here.
This is quite fantastic.
We do have time for questions,
if you have any questions.
Do not ask why my name is Hank.
That's, you know, I
cannot talk about that.
Yes. Oh, he's going to
ask why my name is Hank.
I knew it.
Okay.
>> No. I'm going to
follow up on your request
that we use our imagination.
When I was on Capitol
Hill, I worked on a law
to get the foreign bank account
question on the tax return.
That's the question Paul
Manafort answered dishonestly.
But there's a great
story behind it
and it involves wealthy
business people.
It involves the Chicago
mob, the Cleveland mob,
equal opportunity prostitutes,
one's Caucasian, one's Latin.
But there's a lot of impediments
to my writing that book.
First of all, my writing is all
legal briefs and I can't write,
I can't write dialogue.
>> Hank Phillippi Ryan:
Let me ask you about this.
So you're writing a book about
your experiences on Capitol Hill
with the really complicated
world of banking and finances
and that's -- You have
a very special thing
and I promise I'll
get to your question.
We all have a very
special thing.
Any of us who wants to write
a book or even who thinks
about that a little bit in
their head, you know something
that nobody else knows.
You know things that are special
and you have to ask yourself,
and I ask myself this
every day as I'm writing.
Why do I care about this?
Why do I care about this
because if I don't care,
the reader won't care.
How do I make the reader care?
So if I had to give
you advice about how
to write a complicated
book and you say, oh,
I can't write dialogue and I
don't know how to, you know,
it's a very complicated topic,
I say yeah, isn't that great?
Sit down at your computer
and type chapter one
and see what story
you're telling.
And at every moment ask
yourself why is this important,
what difference does it make
and how can I advance the
story and what is my goal.
Don't worry about -- I
mean, it's interesting
because the idea of writing a
novel is incredibly daunting.
You know, you sit at your
computer and you think,
I have to write a novel.
This is impossible.
But you're writing a page.
You're writing a paragraph.
Just try that.
Tell yourself I'm just
going to write one paragraph
and then I'm going to get up.
See if you can do that
and I bet you can.
And after you write that one
paragraph, write another one.
And then when you get
your first draft done,
worry about making the
dialogue better and worry
about the plot holes
and worry about all that
but you can't write a book
by just thinking about it.
Dennis Lehane always
talks, says that he thinks
about writing his novel so much
that when he comes home he can't
understand why the manuscript
isn't longer because it feels
like he's been working on it.
So that's what I would say.
>> Is it possible to work
with an author that's
a published author
that can make this
into a real story?
>> Hank Phillippi Ryan:
Is it possible to work
with a published author that
could make it into a story?
Is just a casual question?
We'll talk afterwards.
Only you can write the
story that you can write.
There are writing teachers and
there are editors and we'll talk
after this program is over.
Sounds like a good book.
>> Thank you.
>> Hank Phillippi Ryan: See, you
know, there's always something.
Yes?
>> Hello. I'm a college student
and I'm also really interested
in writing these three novels
and there are like a lot
of things that you said
and I'm like, oh yeah!
This is the same thing.
So from the more experienced
perspective, what was one
or more things that you
learned about writing mysteries
as you wrote a lot of mysteries
that you maybe didn't
know when you started?
>> Hank Phillippi Ryan: What
are some things I learned
about writing mysteries
that I may not have
known when I started?
You know what really
the big thing is?
How difficult it is and how full
of self-doubt every writer is.
I mean you heard Annie
Proulx last night, said --
Annie Proulx stood up
on the stage and said,
"I don't really feel
like a writer."
And I thought, wow, you know,
if she has doubts,
everybody has doubts.
Tess Gerritsen once told me,
"With every book I hand in,
I wonder if this is the one
where people will
realize I'm a fraud
and I don't really
know what I'm doing."
Tess Gerritsen!
So you are -- If you
don't have doubts,
you're probably not
being very realistic
about what you're writing.
And if you think, wow,
this is very difficult,
then pat yourself on the back
because that means
you're working hard.
That means you're a writer.
Pat yourself on the
back for going for it.
The thing that will
stop any writer is
that just depressing
darkness of worry
that you're not good enough.
You know, that's
-- Don't do that.
Just throw that away.
Just go for it because you'll
never know what book you have
until you do it.
And worrying isn't going to
make it happen any faster
and it will make your
life be much more dismal.
So embrace your writing.
Go for it and don't worry.
It will turn out
fine, I promise.
It's a Hank promise.
It will turn out fine.
>> Thank you.
>> Hank Phillippi Ryan: Yes?
>> Hello. As just considering
from a writing perspective,
do you think it would be better
or advantageous to be living
with a prosecutor versus
a defense attorney?
>> Hank Phillippi Ryan: Do
I think it would be better
to be living with a
prosecutor or defense attorney,
from the standpoint
of writing a novel?
Yes. Two hilarious
things about that
and that is the funniest
question I've ever heard
and you'll hear why.
One is I can't write
in the morning.
You know, I have
colleagues who get
up at the crack of
dawn and write.
And if I did that, if I got
up at 5 to start writing,
you'd find me at like
5:05 with my head clumped
against the computer,
like dead asleep.
Lee Child said, "Nothing good
ever happens before noon."
And that's sort of how
I feel about writing.
But in my books -- I'm an
investigative reporter,
as you know, and my husband
is a criminal defense attorney
and so there are
times in my books,
which are somewhat
legal oriented,
they're not legal thrillers
but they live in that world,
where there's a legal
question that I have.
And for some reason, I always
come up with this question
that I need to know
what the prosecutor say
or what would the
rule be about this
or how could a judge do that.
It always sort of happens
about 3 in the afternoon,
that's sort of the writing
cycle, so I call my husband
at the office and I
say, hi, sweetheart.
It's me with a legal
question of the day.
And then -- And so it's really
great to be living with a lawyer
to have my own in-house counsel.
That's really helpful.
But the prosecutor or defense
attorney, my new novel,
which I guess I can tell you
the name of, which I sent,
I hit send yesterday on it.
Can you believe [applause],
which was pretty great,
at 11:58 PM because it was due,
you know it was due by midnight.
It's called "The
Murder List" and it is
about a young law student who
was caught between her husband,
a defense attorney, and
her boss, a prosecutor.
So you'll have to read that book
to find out which is better.
Law is all about knowing the
rules and which side you choose,
both sides think they're
the side of justice.
So it just depends
on how you think.
We have a couple minutes.
Yes?
>> Hi. What would you -- What
would be your advice to me,
I have someone very close me
who's writing a science fiction
book and has asked me
to read it, edit it,
give me your opinion, and
I just hate it [laughter].
>> Hank Phillippi
Ryan: Oh, yeah!
Welcome to the world of having
a friend who's a writer.
You're asking -- You have
a friend who wrote a book
and you just really
don't like it.
Is she or he here?
>> No. Might watch C-SPAN.
I don't know.
>> Hank Phillippi Ryan: Okay.
So there is always something
good to be said about a book,
even if it is "what a
great idea that is."
You don't have to
finish with, wow,
but you really didn't do
a very good job with that.
You can tell what
you really think,
I didn't understand this part,
I didn't understand that part,
but, wow, what a good idea.
You're going to -- You
know, when you read reviews
and somebody says five stars
and somebody says one star
and it's the same
book, you know,
you realize that there's room
for many different
opinions in the world.
And some -- You know, my husband
and I can read the same book
and I love it and
he doesn't love it.
So it's okay not to like it.
And she or he is your friend,
tell them something good
about the book and point them
with some constructive
criticism,
perhaps about what you
thought could be better,
like I didn't really know
where this was taking place,
that would be a good thing.
So it's a dilemma and you're a
good pal for caring about it.
Thank you very good question.
Last question.
We have like a minute,
I think, two?
Two minutes.
So you get to have some of it.
>> Sorry. I'm really nervous.
>> Hank Phillippi Ryan:
No, don't be nervous.
>> I have a couple novels
that I'm trying to finish
because I can never seem
to let the characters go.
How do you know when
to end a novel?
>> Hank Phillippi Ryan: How do
you know when to end a novel?
She's saying that she's
written a couple of novels
and she can never let
the characters go.
I know exactly when I'm finished
and that is kind
of a magical thing.
You know how you revise
and you revise and revise
and you're looking
at every word,
and I do that so passionately
because revision
is the ballgame.
Every first draft is terrible.
And then you work on it and work
on it and work on it and try
to find the book in there
that you are really writing.
And I remember with
"Trust Me" it happened.
I was doing a revision and I
was reading along and I forgot
that I wrote the book.
I realized that I was
just reading this story
and not trying to fix it anymore
and that's how I
knew it was done.
You're telling a story with
a beginning, middle and end.
Is it good?
Is it compelling?
When you read it,
do you love it?
If you love it , then your
readers will love it too.
And then just stop and
put it out in the world.
Don't keep that book a secret.
Share that and let
your book live.
>> Thank you.
>> Hank Phillippi
Ryan: Of course.
Last question, real fast.
>> You're a journalist.
I'm a producer in TV news.
You're looking for the
truth in your journalism,
how do not get bogged down
in trying to respect facts
and the truth when you're
writing something that's not
true, a fiction?
How do you not get bogged down
in trying to respect one part
of you and working
on the other part?
>> Hank Phillippi Ryan:
How do I get bogged
down in writing fiction --
>> Not get bogged down.
>> Hank Phillippi Ryan:
Not get bogged down?
How do I get bogged down,
I can really tell you that.
How do I not get bogged
down in the facts?
>> Yeah and trying to respect
the facts in your research
when you're writing fiction.
>> Hank Phillippi Ryan:
You know, when I research,
I put it all in my head and
then I just don't ever look
at the research notebooks again.
I just sort of consume this
information and put myself
in a place that I want the book
to be and then I just write it.
So fiction is different, so
different from doing journalism.
So I try to just relax
and let the book come
out the best way that it can be.
It's fun. My job is to take
a really complicated bunch
of stuff and make it
into a fascinating story
and that's what I
try to do every day.
I am getting the wrap-up sign.
Thank you so much.
Let me just say, remember
the last time you went
to the library and you pulled
out a book and you looked at it.
Think about the author
when you do that.
When you go to a library and
select a book and take it home
with you, you have
made an author happy
and I'm very grateful to
be part of that world.
Thank you so much for coming
here today [applause].